what good are quantum computers I mean
in reality their hype around them is so
maximalized what's their promise there
are two things that quantum computers
will be good at if they can achieve you
in a small fraction of the hype that
they get one is of great interest to
physicists and to find them they will be
wonderful at solving quantum mechanics
problems and giving us insight into the
behavior of quantum mechanics the next
thing a quantum computer could be good
at is precisely because Quantum systems
are doing many things at the same time
if you have quantum mechanical bits
qubits that are doing many things at the
same time especially when you're not
measuring them then you can imagine a
computer that can do many parallel
computations at the same time